comedians but who gives a [ __ ] about
them right you mean they're not special
but the guests we have today is super
special because I love his food he's a
chef but he's not like fruity like
fluffy fluffy fluffy frou-frou you mean
like he's David Chang David Chang is
full of frou frou frou yeah yeah yeah
he's arrogant you know I went to his
restaurant New York once he brought out
the dish and he kind of did a head thing
like [ __ ] you not Roy right not this guy
you know I mean this guy makes food for
the people you know mean the vote for
the working man in fact I'm Roy I'm
telling you right now I was telling
kalila earlier did I say I 200 years
from now go
what would Roy and I would be doing and
correcting the coal mines we'd be
working the coal mines together that's
what the kind of phase you have with the
face I thought you were talking about
his energy energy energy you mean we
work hard you're vain we're [ __ ] yeah
I mean blue-collar in many ways right
not David Chang [ __ ] yeah
who's another white guy I know that
cooks Curtis Stone that Australian farm
snooty [ __ ] Gwen all right I love you
I mean I love your wife
Roy Roy arm started Kogi truck that's
right right why don't we give him a
round of applause boy Troy everybody
credit what yeah I know he does but
that's the one that was that was your
big if scorsese taxi driver that was
your taxi driver taxi right how did you
start that I was broke and hungry I I
was broke I was broke out of a job and
my friend called me he's like let's go
further clubbing so tacos that was the
business plan no yeah
but like did you think regular tacos or
did you go I gotta do my own thing no
Korean barbeque and tortilla those are
the two things he gave me he's like
let's put Korean barbecue inside a
tortilla
we're going from the club we'll [ __ ]
crush it you know all the girls gonna
love us I feed the bouncers we'll do
everything and then yeah just started I
started tinkering from there and it came
natural you know so when you first
because I don't get it so like you know
I was in San Jose and you see the hotdog
people yeah first of all a street dog
yeah but nobody was in San Jose but it's
it's kind of a similar thing throughout
California like any club right
right there's a professional you go out
you're probably out at like 2:00 a.m.
that's all you can get yeah yeah but
what you did though was you've never
just never been done before at all ad
she was laughing there that's the whole
time [ __ ] Mexican lady she couldn't
believe what there was or Asian people
in this really we're all bumping into
each other
shaking her head and that first did
people like not want to eat it or did
they was original just the people just
got they just like I want to try it yeah
we had to kind of force it on people but
soon as they took a bite you know it was
kind of like street performing or you
know in a sense you know like on the
boardwalk or whatever in Venice it was
like we had to really kind of solicit
ourselves and gather people together
because they didn't believe us by the
way we look but as soon as I handed them
a burrito we started with the bouncers
in front of the club and then so soon as
the bouncer bouncers ate it they were
like oh [ __ ] alright you could park
right here and then they started being
salesmen charge of you probably gave it
to for free yes you first Park in front
it was called green door and cabana I
know a green door yeah I've are right
next to you never let me it was Asian
night though it was yeah you know here's
what I love always loved about you is
you have your eyes when you I said your
eyes were pretty right first person that
ever said I know
do you know why I say that why because
they're not just regular ching-chong
guys right no you have a little bit of
crow's feet oh yeah right do you know
why why cuz you smile a lot yes and you
laugh a lot
so whenever somebody has crow even white
dudes have sometimes they have it I
trust them immediately do you have it no
you don't know you don't have james van
der beek does what yeah yeah yeah yeah
so james Van Der Beek has it that's why
when people have it I would like you
know give them a grant and go save save
it for me because I know they won't
spend it Wow that's how invested my
money I I trust dudes with your kind of
eyes bro and I've never seen an Asian
dude with crow's feet right so you must
smile I don't know I was always around
funny people going that mean I grew up
on the street so it's like I was always
around like local neighborhood comedians
and I was always kind of a quiet kid so
I was always laughing so that's a really
great observation
what in k-town k-town Watts Crenshaw
Anaheim orange yeah no let me talk about
watts for a second all right
a Korean dude in watts no was it before
pre or post riots both well I opened the
restaurant recently in watts